I'm an airport boom oh my god I hate
this thank you all from the heaven
Berkeley videos mostly it's just going
to be something that Catherine and I
made as a thanks and also as part of a
very exciting thing that I have created
specifically for our trip to Grand
Rapids dreams are step above and I look
forward to seeing some of you and Grand
Rapids tomorrow I'd seen your videos and
I think they're so chosen and now we're
getting dirty with old Facebook posts I
confess that I've adapted to your time
Joe at least now I don't have to watch
you too
you
Oh even more tonight
I'd much rather touch
and nothing
a nerdfighter like me won't you stay up
on that I'm skyping me we could go on a
day to the library too bad you don't
live anywhere near me over
Mantic lunch we blurb some love books
and blenderize arm use all of their
tables gave us dirty looks do a reading
of blue get stuck in my pants if we
could hang out IRL I do my happy dance
so even though tonight I got a date with
my bookshelf
I'd much rather touching hug you
maybe something else
won't you be
won't you stay up on that Scot me we
slow-danced to music that's royalty-free
to pad you don't live anywhere near me
oh you know tonight I got the tape with
my bookshelf I much rather touch love
you and something else
like me won't you stay day to the
library to read you don't leave any
Neri
additionally I'm going to be speaking in
Missoula at an event about social
networking it's $5 for students $10 for
everybody else Tuesday of next week at
5:30 at the Missoula Art Museum I will
be there speaking about social
networking and about nerdfighters 200
people who don't know what nerdfighters
are so that'll be fun
and John I will see you in a couple of
hours bathroom